he is the executive director of the
morad center at villanova long time
executive with the green bay packers and
the host of the business of sports
podcast andrew brantpack here on the
show how are you sir
great minds think alike that moment
right right before i think you contacted
me last night we sent out a tweet
virtually the same time
yeah which for people who don't know was
that at the same time we have a
triple threat from aaron rodgers he
could be executive of the year for
signing randall cobb he could be mvp
while also being a team owner
a great minds think alike yes that's why
i just thought to myself he owns the
bears he's the mvp quarterback of the of
the uh of the packers but also a de
facto general manager
and you know i did give some ronda gouda
kunst here because again aj dillon was a
pick that
you know
uh we were all torturing him for because
rogers wanted that weapon you know and
as a matter of fact not only do they not
get ayuke they they watch the niners get
them and then they move up to draft
jordan love and then get him another
runner back when aaron jones is clearly
the guy there and sure enough look who's
a two-headed monster last night when
they need it uh jones and dylan
but the guy who got in the end zone a
couple times is the guy that roger says
i want to be here in in uh in randall
cobb so it's kind of like you know
all working right now andrew yeah i mean
we're going to talk about our guy aaron
but i think organizationally and i was
part of that organization as you as
people know for 10 years
that is a huge win organizationally
because
you've got your superstar aaron but
you've got this
infrastructure that a lot of people like
you just said we're criticizing
in terms of not even giving matt
lafloren his incredible win-loss record
the respect it deserves and certainly
not the front office
well that was a win for the front office
and the coaching staff if ever was a win
for the front office and coaching staff
you have to play the game made by a guy
they picked up off the arizona by the
way practice squad
russell douglas
you have a second round pick that was
panned last year
running through what was one of one of
if not the top rated defense in the
league
and coaching wise they got they realized
they didn't have their top three
receivers
and it was a run oriented ball
controlling or in a time of possession
oriented win
over the only undefeated team on the
road
on a short week that's a huge win and
then in a short week to come up um with
a a way to get the plays called into
the defense uh with you know joe barry
out because of covet 19 protocols uh
passing game coordinator and defensive
backs assistant you know jerry gray and
kirk olividi the linebackers coach you
put something in place in short order
you know that might have been in place
you know just in case to break glass you
take it out of a drawer but you still
have to execute it you know on a short
week and then in a game that's so big it
really did all all work out right there
so um
how how do you
think matt lafleur has grown into this
job because it sure looks like he's
comfortable he's just got like this
you know the first year uh he he he
looked like obviously he was new to the
scene and new to the job and
we're we're just wondering who he is but
i haven't interviewed him yet and i look
forward to it now he's got like some
sort of swagger on the sideline like
he's barking at people you know like and
he he and rogers appear to be totally
locked at the hips standing next to each
other making the same gestures to to the
referees when they're
uh you know on defense it it it really
looks different to me andrew yeah that's
rich and there's you know the obvious
answer that grown into this relationship
he's grown into the role over three
years but
it's not like we're talking about a
coach that came in and won six games
right this coach came in and has been to
two count them two
consecutive nfc championship games
i mean i don't do all the the stats and
all that it just seems like if there's a
coach that has the first three-year
record of matt lafleur
it's a pretty damn short list i mean
it's like one or two coaches in history
that's come in and had the wins and as i
said before i'm not sure he gets the
respect he deserves because of one aaron
rodgers
and that's the sort of the blessing and
the curse of coaching a superstar
but we'll see you know this
he came from tennessee and obviously
places before that the rams in
washington but
he came from tennessee which everyone uh
equates with derek henry
uh he is really wanting to run the ball
and that sounds odd when you have aaron
rodgers but it seems like it's coming
into focus now and again the top three
receivers were out last night
but what a balanced offense and aaron
could sort of rely on a different kind
of game plan
and then pick a spot with randall cobb
and aaron jones being the lead receiver
yeah i mean 37 attempts for rogers last
night throwing it and 34 on the ground
for a buck 51 and a score i mean that is
exactly what you mean by balance andrew
brant here on the rich eisen show so
okay so we've established that lefleur
is grown into his own now 33 and seven
um as the uh i mean he's 13-1 and 13-1
and now seven and one right so 33-1 33-7
now as coach of the green bay packers
and he and the relationship with rogers
clearly seems to be bonded
um and rogers is guy who's like let's
get randall cobb and okay let's get
let's give aaron a little something let
him wet his beak a little bit on on the
roster and then cobb comes up big um and
then everyone else is performing around
it is it possible yeah that we're
watching rogers fall back in love with
everything about the green bay packers
soup to nuts
and that the the off-season of
discontent will actually with this
regular season lead to a longer stay if
not his entire career do you think that
that is possible andrew yeah my friend a
lot unpack here and i want to lead with
my head not my heart because i as people
know me from twitter and they're in the
games i'm still a big fan i'm still
biased
but i just i sort of diagnosed this
whole off season
as aaron who was a good soldier in year
one about the pick of jordan love where
we had a different experience with brett
15 years ago when we picked aaron
kind of after the championship game was
like what's going on here because i get
the feeling
they want to move to love in 2022
and in so many words i thought his
people were saying to the packers let's
just do it now you know why wait a year
just do it now let's move them on you're
going to do it next year
and of course the packers in management
they wanted the mvp performance again
before
moving on to love
and they ultimately i guess for lack of
better word won that battle
and aaron has a contract accommodation
but not till twenty after twenty twenty
two
but if you remember there's kind of
loose language when in the reporting
that after 2021
packers and aaron will sort of figure it
out
and the way i read that was he'll be
involved in what team he picks to be
traded to
so i have always thought that 2022
was the separation date
between aaron and the packers i've
thought that
and if you're putting a gun to my head
i still think it but
my heart says wow
he he's he's so invested in this team he
loves the team
this may be sort of a real dramatic year
in the history of the packers and aaron
and maybe it could continue
but there's two parts to this there's
the aaron side
and i don't think his feelings have been
assuaged completely
i do think he doesn't have this warmth
for the front office
and that has continued but they're
professional they're living with each
other for six months
and there's the packers side
where yeah we waited three years to move
to erin years ago
i don't think they want to wait three
years for jordan love
and i know you've got the mvp but i
don't i think it's two years
so i would think this would still
require rich
a change in attitude for both sides
well i mean the the change in attitude
from roger's side
um
i i i can't attest to right i mean
the fact of like he he's a singular
person that i don't think you could
compare him to anybody else in the nfl
not just talent wise but
you know uh neck up between the temples
wise i mean in his i mean a perfect
example of that is
last night he's being taken down
by his uh numbers on the back of his
jersey and the takedown is somewhat slow
enough for him to be spun around and
make eye contact with the official who
he thinks should be calling a flag for a
horse collar tackle like he's actually
has the presence of mind to find the
appropriate zebra that he wants a call
from in the middle of the play i mean
like i i don't
i mean you don't talk about presence of
mind and awareness and and clearly he
now has that
mentally
for whatever he says that his approach
to life allows him to live in the moment
so on and so forth so i can't speak to
that right but what i can i think speak
to
is you know the football aspect of this
wouldn't it be complete football
rostering franchise mal practice
to tell aaron rodgers at this stage
certainly when you're seeing brady do it
to age 44
you know how can you move on to a guy
that's totally
um new
potentially very talented and i know he
could be there for a very long time
but you're seeing what's going on in
chicago right now i mean you're seeing
what's going on in new york you're
seeing what's going on in jacksonville
you want a piece of that
by telling rogers
adios i know really like that's
malpractice to me that i think i could
speak to andrew what about you
if you were interviewing me 15 years ago
and i probably wouldn't come on because
i was with the organization yes you'd
ask the exact same question the exact
100 percent same words
instead of rogers and love it would be
far been rogers
and there was no question i got more in
those three years where aaron was a
backup which was
you can't do this you can't move from
brett favre to an unknown
you just are you what do you want to end
up like these teams with no quarterback
like the bears at the time
so it's
and again
i am not suggesting jordan love will be
anything like aaron rodgers
but at some point these decisions have
been made
yeah the packers could go another year
but then love's into the fourth year of
his contract and
i it just feels to me
like this has been the plan
and if they win the super bowl and
rogers is off in the sunset to a new
team so be it
i'm saying what i said to you on text
rich my heart says more rogers
my head says they're still going to move
on why is that because you think rogers
is still
again his answer he gave last night
about living in the moment and he made
an adjustment last year
um that he's you know by the way he's
taken that on the golf course you see
what he did to try and carry deshambo
against phil and brady too right i mean
like it's not just
it's not just football he's clearly
doing it everywhere for himself
when i when we brought him in first time
after drafting him
i just noticed it right away just kind
of this
first of all off the charts intelligence
and vocabulary you don't see with with
frankly a lot of players and
this sort of sense of calm and i just
distribute attributed it to california
northern california cool
but it's just this sense of calm and and
things not taking things too seriously
in this wry sense of humor
and then as i've told you before we had
those two off seasons where brett spent
the time in mississippi
and i had greg jennings and donald
driver and james jones
coming up to our offices and saying
i mean oh my god
oh my god this guy
i mean we love brett we love brett but
oh my god
this young guy rogers
so we knew now i don't know what's going
on in that scenario with love but love
had that this off season right rogers
wasn't there love had that
so they probably know a lot more about
love than they did a year ago
and but roger's different from farv
though right i mean you know rogers
doesn't have this this start streak that
that was consuming a lot either um i
don't know if ron i know rogers has
suffered injuries but
i think he's in a better physical place
than like at least when you moved on
from far
you know you kind of figured he didn't
have much longer to go i mean rogers you
could literally get him for another six
years because of what brady's doing and
if he wants to do the same damn thing
right i mean
[Music]
yeah i don't know it's not just it's not
just like hey he might go somewhere else
for two years he could have a whole
other career
somewhere else if you if you or you
could have a whole other
you know dynastic run
right with him in green bay in the same
way that brady did after garoppolo was
dispatched
andrew just and i'm trying to put myself
in brian's shoes and matt lafleur
they're both at whatever you want to
call it at fault for picking jordan love
i'm trying to think about 2019 season
and if they detected
decline
in aaron's game you couldn't he was
terrific he was sublime that he didn't
win
these past two years i'm wondering what
happened for them to move up to take
love so
you know it may be as simple as
you know i i remember nfl network people
at this jordan love could be a top 10
pick you know maybe it's simple as oh my
god look at the value right
but we'll see i mean
there's a lot to play out here god
willing he doesn't get injured uh if he
continues to play this way obviously
going to force the packers hand but
don't discount aaron here don't discount
that it's all kumbaya with aaron and the
organization
and
when i heard that leflore and murphy and
goodkins all made trips to la this off
season and still had issues
that's still a problem
andrew brandt here on the rich eisen
show i've got about three minutes left
for something that obviously could be uh
talked about for three years but uh who
do you think uh leaked the emails
uh from john gruden and what do you
think they were
was that possibly to get everyone's
attention on the other stuff with the
washington football team that has not
been revealed or was it just a straight
gruden play or
what what what tea leaves can you read
on on that
my initial thought was someone from the
washington football team but now i just
think that that would be so silly and
short-sighted if that happened because
look what's happened the focus has
turned back on them for me and others
why was it an oral report why is this in
a drawer of a tenure
of treating women the wrong way at the
washington football club how does that
happen so someone had to realize if it's
from washington
this is going to turn back against them
or maybe they were so short-sighted they
didn't realize that
i'm guessing someone in the league rich
because
you know you have business targets here
where
bruce allen's a target again that sort
of leads back to washington but
demori smith a leak a day before his
reelection vote and they've had good
negotiations from their side with demori
smith
so i just think it's somewhere on the
management side my initial thought was
washington but it's turned against them
as we now see
so i don't really see that so i'm
guessing someone either connected the
league through maybe even law firm
or someone in the league office what do
you think gruden's next steps are i just
have a feeling he's sitting there you
know not saying anything right now
just laying low but i i have a feeling
we have not heard from him the last yet
what do you think well my first you know
me in my line there will be lawyers yes
sir that's why i'm asking you
that's why i'm asking you yeah to sue
the a the raiders be the league
and see both
and
i don't think mark davis wanted to fire
him so i don't know if it's the raiders
or maybe more bigger sources than him
in terms of his reappearance you know
time has healed wounds for a lot less
and
i i don't see him on the sideline
if he wants perhaps media but it'll be
time right there'll be a lot of time
between when we see him again and do you
think there will be some form mark davis
says he wants to see a written report
that there was no written report on the
washington football team
investigation he wants to see one and he
called for it what do you think do you
think that's just one owner talking what
do you think yeah and i think he's the
owner that's always still like his dad
seen his maverick and they've shouted
him down and
they're going to hope like everything
this goes away there'll be a new drama
and no one will be talking about it
again andrew thanks for the call greatly
appreciate it sir
thank you there you go check everyone
out uh check andrew brand out at andrew
brant
right here on the rich eisen show i
follow him you should too he's a
terrific follow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here